France 3 avec les centes Leclerc vous
présente un livre un
[Applaudissements]
jour en préface au tome 4 Pierre Nora le
maître d'œuvre de l'ensemble de SEP
volumes publiés par galimar sous le
titre lieu de mémoire écrit son
entreprise comme un monument
cathédralesque et labyrintique on ne
saurait mieux dire d'un ouvrage au fond
sans précédent qui se propose tout
simplement d'écrire autrement l'histoire
de France la démonstration est
particulièrement explicite dans les
trois derniers livres sous-titré les
France qui viennent de paraître 60
contributions du au meilleur furet Osouf
agulon vinoc Juliard Chartier et cetera
dans le premier tome les contrastes Fran
et ois la droite et la gauche Paris et
la province dans le tome 3 les symboles
viselet Lasco alisia Jean d'c
Charlemagne le tome 2 est le plus
séduisant qui traite des constantes on
s'enchantera des textes de Marc Fumaroli
sur la conversation de Noémie
sur la galanterie de Pascal Ori sur la
gastronomie ce sont des livres à lire au
fil du désir et du temps libre on en
mesurera les agréments et aussi les
limites les illustrations en noir et
blanc seulement la grande difficulté à
synthétiser et si les lieux de mémoire
en fait ne traduisaient qu'une heureuse
démarche de
[Musique]
journaliste France 3 avec les centre
Leclerc vous a présenté un livre un
jour